to surreal prisons are these some real
prisons or are they escaping one tired
of being online amongst billions of
perps children beings who lack access to
running water or the millions who
despite breakthroughs in agriculture and
farming remains starving and the soil no
longer eats oil
[Music]
[Applause]
and still designing my trainers ain't
following fashion it's always me who i
came and then got a twin i know she
copied me we ain't the same i don't know
you from adam so why you act like we're
neighbors we ain't friends i just
couldn't give an effort we
[Music]
if i'm famous faded cute ain't no better
way i can say this because it don't
matter about the stairs i could give it
the tail and i take it in open it is i
still flowing the triggers can't wait to
hit the wheel whipping random mercedes i
want ferraris and betty's one for
zarchie and fendi you see my face on the
telly you scream my name like i'm jerry
i run the house like i'm jerry got mr
thomas jerry jerry jerry you know they
call me jerry jerry jeremy
jerry jerry you know they call me jerry
jerry jerry springer i'm a cherry cherry
jerry
cherry cherry cherry
cherry cherry cherry
cherry cherry cherry this year i'm doing
it
[Music]
just stick and i ain't trying to insult
you i'm just telling you what i think i
got a lot up on my mind i'm just hoping
you take the hint
trying to cut you at the spot no no no
pick up everybody making drugs
remember when i used to have a job all
along i could barely keep up with the
squad couldn't wait to hear the wheel
whipping around at mercedes i want
ferraris and babies jimmy choo and
giuseppe i'm on the block like i'm jenny
you scream my name like i'm jerry you
see my face on the telly got mr
[Music]
you know they call me jerry jerry jeremy
jerry jerry
jerry jerry
[Music]
on the table you see my face on the
telly you scream my name like i'm jerry
i run a house like i'm jerky i run a
house like i'm chilling yeah i run a
house like i'm drilling got mr tom on my
celly i run the house like i'm jerky i
run a house like i'm trying to run a
house like i'm trying got mr
[Music]
for the
[Music]
[Music]
lyrics in the bottom of the caption
whole city came through for the function
on the ball like a young ted dancing
two instrumental whole crew in the
middle looking like a fraction cut
through in the living room you gotta get
in two shots like we bulletproof waves
ain't made trying to wait in the
swimming pool i feel like mick didn't
like 65 but it's 16 and i'm still
cutting up like i'm guillotine it'd be
like i'm the one like
[Music]
what you really trying
[Music]
[Applause]
soon as we say
[Music]
hope you didn't call me
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
looking like king they already know what
my drink is they already know what that
stink is cause we swim in the deep end
we do what we want to try to get you
back your girl and she
wants you
it's been a long night i could see the
sun boom your friends could tell them
come through
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
like
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
bye
[Music]
know
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
excuse me
yes
[Music]
i think i met her in the
[Music]
for the mad ones but i'm never scared
about you that's a little more
[Music]
i wonder if you know
[Music]
i just fall apart
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all i know
[Music]
fall apart
[Music]
a stroke
[Music]
look at you
what a few
ladies
[Music]
but you need
[Music]
baby just give me a shot i know the
flavor of love
baby
[Music]
baby i know you're tired of
[Music]
it goes
[Music]
baby i know you're worth much more
[Music]
you want something more
[Music]
baby i know how you feel
[Music]
please
i know how you feel
i know
baby i know how you feel
you want something more something real
[Music]
baby i know how you feel
[Music]
bill
hello
[Music]
energy
[Music]
energy
[Music]
energy energy
[Music]
energy
[Music]
push it push it make it right my moment
get it get it moving on feel the power
taking flight push push
[Music]
energy energy
energy
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
she's hot
so sweet
the kind of girl
[Music]
[Music]
he's
[Music]
she's probably
[Music]
she's on fire
burning
[Music]
a real woman
i love her
[Music]
hold on tight there's nothing you can do
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone
hello everyone and welcome to the final
day of the play for all charity streams
my name is morsein and it is my absolute
pleasure to be joined by lucy james
hi
jan ochoa what's up what's up
jeff bakala
hello how are you and jeff gerstmann
hi hey how's it going hello yes that's
that's right gamespot and giant bomb are
combining our forces for the final
charity stream
we're gonna pull our energies together
and uh pour it into this extremely
chaotic game that we're playing
um and we're going to do it in service
of ray you oh my god just cut to the
crazy
uh
we are going to do it in aid of
ablegamers we are of course raising
money for um ablegamers a organization
that works tirelessly to combat social
isolation and make gaming more
accessible for people with disabilities
and i've said it a few times over the
course of the week but obviously the
last year has been difficult for a lot
of people
um you have no doubt felt a feeling of
isolation and loneliness and
there are
ways that you can use gaming to combat
that but for a lot of people
the idea of getting into games and
playing with others is a lot trickier
than you might imagine and ablegamers is
an organization that tries to break down
those barriers so
please do try and donate to tinyroll.com
for slash
2021
um and yeah all the money goes to an
amazing cause can someone please explain
what the hell is happening on this
screen what this game is
it's pretty self-explanatory
i mean i'm
you know it's i'm goku
and i'm dabbing in a fountain
uh here let me will this make it make
more sense for you if i speed this up is
this now how do you get it
can i get my case
how fast can you yeah that's the super
saiyan dab i'm surprised he's not turned
super saiyan yet
um
so
who
what is that
uh crazy fraud you know
from the hit ringtone
is he anatomically correct though like
the real crazy frog
does he have a tiny pee pee
well so
mr bakalar if you can come here off the
phone real quick so we can share this
thing uh i think crazy frog would be at
carl's like tummy
oh stop bending like that please
yeah like one to one yeah yeah
yeah there you go yeah
mario to crazy frog is like
mid-chest
why does mario just look like he's
suffering from heat stroke
yeah yeah mario makes me very
uncomfortable
yeah i don't like how the real finger
tips are touching the floor
i need to get some get someone a little
more like stream friendly
there we go
yeah
we've got a giant i'm a metal gear wreck
so that's nice
you changed into that seamlessly
yeah you like that yeah
metal gear wrecks can dab but not that
well this isn't a dabbing metal gerex
it's jack frost finally jack frost is
here yay
oh boy
oh goodness
can jack frost dab yes yeah the answer
is yes thank god
great news i will i found what
donut homer
oh
wow
i
this is am
you never thought you'd see donna homer
dabbing on the internet that's just i
don't know what's going on definitely
not this fast yeah it's just for charity
oh oh tellytubby is that uh this is
that's pope yeah oh i don't like that
for the folks at home i guess let's uh
let's pop in here
uh lucy do you have any requests
um
oh okay hang on hang on him
uh
sky is the limit
could you scroll down oh no literally
we'll search something and then it'll
probably oh yeah okay um
from futurama let's just type in
professor see what we get
professor no [ __ ] what i said
professor leighton's there
the best of the professors
there we go
uh someone's playing as is that
who i don't know who that is
it's a doritos bag here
i've i've switched to daisuke kuzer from
uh yakuza
to see if this doritos bag can dab
okay
oh my god
that's the answer is yes
just here
i don't know if michael hyam is watching
but i'm just gonna dab as his one of his
favorite yakuza characters so
michael this one's for you
yeah
this is great someone hitting golf balls
what am i hearing
oh this is a giant nintendo 64. go ahead
is it not dabbing oh hold on hold on uh
lucy and tam you need to see this let me
[Music]
trying to sync my dab up with uh
ramona's giant box of craft dinner over
here oh oh no she's chucky cheese now
close enough okay hold on
oh my god
there's that ae86
wait is there a chicken dancing on the
top where's that chicken come from
there's two who's the other car i don't
know
what's happening
what
what
there's a lot of explosions currently
happening
oh my god that car's just drifting
around the fountain
hey isn't it f9 day or is it was that oh
it is oh yeah happy f9 day to us oh hold
on here we go what am i doing
are you getting dominic toretto oh of
course
i will be i'll join you in four minutes
i have to wait for it to download oh no
okay
a lot of these workshop models are
getting ripped out of other games
directly and stuff so i feel like it's a
matter of time i mean there is a vin
diesel model in multiple video games so
someone should we just reenact the
entire movie
i mean probably but like someone will
eventually have to upload that if they
haven't already so there you go i have a
vin diesel
okay okay like wheel man aravind diesel
like what are we this is
i just searched vin diesel
yeah
that we should just stream um fast and
furious crossroads
you know they're always
always weird there's no ludicrous model
and there's no tyrese gibson model
[Laughter]
uh
[Laughter]
incredible
fantastic uh
some of the giant bomb chat brings up a
big uh
is there a 50 cent model i mean 50 cent
blood on the sand a classic
iconic
oh my god it's the one from bulletproof
which is even older than blood on the
sand so it'll probably look worse
oh my god oh my god
and
[Music]
oh
classic jeff
[Music]
yeah if you need to hit this big ass
ramp i mean you need
you need some equipment
yes yes todd hello todd
what can you tell us about star field
it's just reskin skyrim
you'll play it and you will be broken
uh it will be as broken and you will
once again play as a stealth archer who
is playing like a laser in my face
oh my god
look bob from tekken arrived and i can
hide behind him oh my god oh [ __ ]
oh look at me bob
there's a lot of people here i don't i
don't know how we got it yeah where did
all these people come from all of a
sudden we got ourselves a little
little flash mob
okay hold on
this gundam is dabbing
that's condoms dab we got we got bobby
hill is that bobby hill
yep
it's a little bobby hill dabbing his way
through uh the lobby here
wow there's a lot of persona in here oh
you just searched me i'm gonna stop i'm
just gonna walk into the sea
who are you going for let's just be this
chibi joker that's the f-zero car over
there this is not cheap at all is that
ninja
someone playing as ninja oh so is kermit
the frog
oh man
this is the door we
[Applause]
i guess let's just see if we can get
everyone to dab
so now someone's playing marchera's dad
in his underwear
oh
very specific
that must have come from either the
jackass game or one of those tony hawks
i feel like that model's in there
somewhere here we go yeah
real squad whole squad
wait time
i'm gonna join on you
all right
i'll see you
let me get
who is this icarly
yes
[Laughter]
what if they have an icarly video okay
i remember there being one yeah this is
almost certainly an icarly game
let me let me get uh old soleil
uh someone is asking jeff if they have
fred durst from fight club
that's a great question oh that is
pretty good one
nope does it well if if they do it's not
found by just typing fred durst but fred
from scooby doo comes back
i'm following a giant isabel from animal
crossing hello everyone how do i change
what i look like
okay i'm in a minute and then workshop
okay
um
oh my god that slimer is horrifying
watch what happens when i dunk it's so
bad
this is the comedy central logo from the
90s
why
wait can slimer dab
oh hell yeah
who's robocop
why am i so big
i look like i've just walked into him
i'm like
mom said it was my turn to use the
xbox i found a great one should we play
a game here sure
this isn't the game
there's a little bit more to it
holy [ __ ]
i don't like this gigantic scenario head
at all oh
i'm going to run up and pull it i'm
going to shoot my scorpion spear into
your nose
let me dab i can dab
oh god
just dead on the floor next to a plant
oh no
did you see gandalf
honestly
why is any of this happening um how's it
going
robocop was break dancing
someone is shooting bubbles so that's
slimers
slimer's not all right
wait gandalf only has a face on one side
yeah it's a gandalf stand me it's not
gandalf
finally uh joker and spongebob can just
sit and have a chat
yeah just some people guys being dudes
well we can head off to the arcade or
the casino and and do something for them
yeah yeah
let's go to the arcade and play some
redemption games if we can earn some
tickets all right you
what are you now jeff
yeah who are we following yeah
with the day i'm up in the air
oh how do you use the jet pack uh you
don't have any
yeah oh man
okay we're all following
yeah so we head
activity
and
and now there's all these things are
going to be taken
there's so many people here uh you have
to buy some tokens you have to exchange
some money for tokens if you don't have
any already
okay
all right
got them and uh
well.com for such pray for all 2021 yes
yes
more than ten dollars you can pick the
current skin on me
[Music]
i just want to keep spending tokens
like scorpion would do well with the
wheel of fire a little skee-ball
oh whack-a-mole
how do you buy tokens
uh there's token machines by the door
don't let me interact with them you
gotta you have a button you gotta zoom
in
and press e over the little red button
oh my god grow up
what is this
i bought too many tokens
worth it
oh my god
my brain is slightly breaking just like
having broccoli looking directly at
waluigi
oh i don't like this i don't like this
bot but with homer's head
who is this on a pogo stick
oh that was a bad toss
oh i have to charge the throw got it
yeah yeah
nice francis york morgan
on a pogo stick
oh my god my game has crashed my game is
crashed
what's this york morgan on a pogo stick
crash my game you bought too many tokens
yeah
okay i'm playing wheel of fair
he's playing skee-ball with my friends
yes
so this whole thing is still early
access so you'll still see a lot of
places in here that are like coming soon
or like uh halfway done and they've got
a trello board and everything about the
updates they're making and
all this stuff it's uh i haven't played
it so they've updated a lot of these
arcade games since the last time i
played to change some of the physics and
do a few other things that uh
you know smooth out the experience a bit
uh i crashed
yeah i crashed i crashed yeah that ski
ball baby
uh
left control
okay
there's some games upstairs as well
uh how is wheel of fire like a gang
like this is you just pull the thing
yeah i mean you pretty much win every
time
oh man i need a hundred thousand tickets
to get a mower scooter
worth it
some stuff is uh you can get with
tickets or with uh your your u-bucks or
whatever they are and so you can kind of
get things
gambling or doing casino stuff or
some of the other mini games will give
you um
most the other mini games will give you
money as well so there's kind of a
handful different ways to get some
things
oh instruments are still coming okay
yeah
yeah
air hockey's not in yet
pool looks like it's in
donation from chinese cosmo says please
jan be either iggy's wrecking balls or
blast call
what what these wrecking balls are blast
core
yeah n64 action i mean it was just the
25th uh birthday of uh
the n64 right oh trash of this
oh did i lose my tokens
oh i'm so bad
i accidentally left a bunch of tokens on
the floor
you could do that oh you have to pick up
your tickets uh
they'll pick up automatically i don't
know what the deal is but like i feel
like they will usually pick up
automatically but
uh we've got a bunch of donations in do
we want to read them like they go all
the way back to i think the last one is
craig gilbert
yeah the last one i saw
i'll read these out since my game is
loading
uh we got ten dollars from vincent
cortez and then we got ten dollars from
anonymous twenty dollars from anonymous
twenty dollars from anonymous uh that's
just people who have chosen not to give
us their name not hacking group
anonymous we're not affiliated with them
thank you for that
matt hawking gave thirty dollars and
said i won't be able to watch this
week's uh today's streams but it's been
a joy to participate again for an
amazing charity much love to lucy and
tim for the awesome job uh hosting uh
awesome thank you
um
says good luck have fun and gave ten
dollars
and jacob
uh i'm gonna try and pronounce your
second name but i will almost certainly
screw it up jacob
crudesfeld
gave fifty dollars uh debuts gave five
dollars tim gave 50 ed gave 50. toast
gave 20. box gave 20 and said amazing to
see giant bomb and gamespot together
uh anonymous gave 20.
chris shomo gave 25 and said uh love the
gsn gb cruise together for ablegamers
hell yeah
and then we got ruchino who's been
donating a whole bunch this week 9.95
cents they've been such a fun time with
the charity streams really nice work to
the whole team
good luck with the final day
uh boxer mega man gave five dollars
oh my gosh
efren gave a hundred dollars and said i
can't watch the stream but i get i got
paid today so i can download thank you
so much
and then we'll go uh way tech lee who
gave 25. uh cam connick said i need
pepsi man please thank you
so someone see if they can find pepsi
man got it
drew bunker gave 20 anonymous gave 40
danny glover
danny glover gave 20 dollars to keep up
the great work
i don't know if i feel like it's always
danny glover yeah
uh 20 dollars from anonymous again and
yeah that's it we're up to date our
current uh
current uh total is ten thousand nine
hundred sixty-five thank you so much
everyone
pepsi man
no it's so jacked
oh yeah oh wow that's why i drink i mean
i drink diet pepsi but you know that's
why i'm so jacked
i've i've recently moved to diet
sugar-free and
caffeine-free pepsi and diet coke
wow
it's it's been interesting and uh
somehow they've made managed to
replicate the taste of normal diet coke
perfectly
and how's the the no caffeine i mean
were you were you big on caffeine before
and i was very big on caffeine i've also
gone to like caffeine-free coffee as
well
really oh and yeah it's been working out
well like i feel
i i lack energy in the morning but i
trade that off for not having the crash
and the end of the day yeah
sure um
the tricky part is like
the first two weeks of it is the
headaches that you gotta fight through
yeah
oh yeah i totally have a caffeine
problem it's really it's really bad
jan come on
what's happening here
where where are you
this man
there's just like a group of us staring
at this uh
deceased man on the stairs oh no
somebody help this man
absolutely massive isabel playing an
arcade over here
what a unit
i've turned on my like a torch but i
don't know how
f
uh commander shepard's join how do i dab
uh c and then c and then on the yeah uh
is
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah look at him
i just i just wanted to play some games
with my friends
oh my god
i just
stopped
if folks in the chat want to suggest
characters i can try and find them as
well
uh i wish there was a photo the hideo
kojima model in here is not the model
i'm looking for i feel like there's a
difference
there's a there's a better kojima model
to be made and deployed
oh my god someone went through the
trouble of
getting rash from battle toads in this
labor love right there
in it
i don't think we've said what server
we're on but i feel like it's probably a
bunch of giant bomb folks uh yeah it
seems like we've seen
ben janka from our teams in there yeah
oh this is this isn't even oh this is a
nickname like that
oh i'm upset about that pickle oh that's
yeah that's that pickling right
uh
okay
okay all right i'm gonna just play some
whack-a-mole
i wish i had a jet pack one day lucy
look i'm just gonna well i'm i'm
i'm the untitled goose now
so i just feel like that's a way to
create max uh trouble
oh wow you need a lot of tickets to buy
stuff huh
so i think i think i might have found i
i well i don't know like everyone's
gonna have their own strategy i'm sure
but they're upstairs there's a machine
called
where is it uh
oh where'd it go
a tornado that seems like a pretty good
it's only five tokens and i've gotten
like 210 tickets for five tokens seems
like a pretty good
exchange rate if you're looking to grind
yeah let's grind it out
bad news everyone
what happened the guest the guest are
here
oh no
oh you think that's bad hulk hogan is
here too oh no
oh no
oh this whole lucha is absolutely
whacking a mole over here
yeah and they have glasses now
yeah
how do you play this
oh no
oh god
should we uh hop into this arena and
start
this whack-a-mole is
is pretty fun it's a laser tag uh arena
also
oh i would love to try because no one
ever seems to be queued up for it oh
yeah let's do it yeah
all right where is
it uh crash bandicoot i'm all head
downstairs towards the door
um
that's probably no no hang on i'm not
down there yet i accidentally hit the
butt i accidentally got into a game hang
on all right there we go
all right where are the stairs
oh wait time there i see you
uh so we okay
here we go
hey time i'm rex
now oh hell yeah
um
[Music]
there's a pretty good shepherd model as
well so it's directly across the plaza
next to the bowling alley this place
just says laser tag
this feels a lot like being in vegas
yeah
i miss it
all right let's go to the
heart attack grill after
oh god
this is exactly like vegas actually yeah
yeah
yeah smoke
oh i'll join and then yeah if you just
walk up to the screen and hit e you'll
you'll queue up for it
sick wow there's okay
here we go
okay
can't tell if i'm in or not
i don't think i'm in
uh it doesn't pop anything up
you just have to hit you once
oh yeah i think i'm full game
elimination it looked like it was twelve
twelve was the max
let's do a second or another yeah
can we
i think we maybe have to wait until the
other one's finished yeah the rounds are
gone yeah
uh i'm gonna stream snipes in
i'm just gonna watch jen
i'm scared
it actually looks pretty good you do
really well right is not bad
someone else is their cheese on the
shepherd spy model
oh okay i did not know lucy
no i'm rex oh i'm outside i didn't make
it i didn't make it in
oh this matters this makoto is hitting
me with a giant uh pleasuring device
someone said jonathan ferguson gameplay
when
i got shot and it said i needed to
recharge and i didn't know what that
meant i did not make it back to the
recharge station i guess
there's like a little um battery packs
yeah
it's like qzar
someone is playing as tony hawk but with
a rocket launcher
i think i see benjenko
who is ringing me from sausalito
i don't know
hey
team aqua wins
oh two out of three oh okay who needs
siege when you have this you know right
exactly
i'm just gonna steal this stay real well
we've got a few more donations julia's
got fifty dollars uh great work hey
thank you game sport and giant bomb
thank you julia
big denim ten dollars has ten dollars
worth of space coins cheers
i am under the bed i think that is uh 50
and then imran final donation from me
love all the work uh done this week
looking forward to more giant bomb
crossovers oh there will be some oh oh
oh oh
was that a
guy
that was at the right
there oh wait time
i have a bunch more on my screen if you
want me to take
yeah girlfriend uh we got nate rfb with
20 thank you pompo with ten dollars the
kitty killer with fifty dollars thank
you oh uh
parkour
23 47.
is the quiet man the mom wife or rascal
from the ps1 game rascal in this oh i
need to see if the quiet man isn't here
quiet man's a great shot
i can't change my appearance yet
i'll have a look for you thank you king
minion
uh we got 200 from jacob owens
uh thank you so much you said can we
just watch timor play bloodborne all day
tv
they don't have the quiet man jen but
they do have starbucks clerk oh
all right we got we got something at
least
jeff i don't know if you're doing well
in laser tag right now
i think i i i
knocked a lot of people out and
i'm sorry you're about to say something
oh no i just got a word i got a word
from but i'm supposed to be in a
one-on-one right now that i didn't
rearrange
um
we got justin delabar with twenty
dollars let's get some noid up in here
dudes freak that was annoyed earlier
right yeah it was yeah i saw annoyed
uh we got twi
i've discovered a hack for this laser
tag mode lucy if you look behind you
oh no i'm standing directly behind you
but you can't see are you are you
playing i'm invisible
i'm just an invisible character
i'm just
gonna all i can see is like
oh my god someone is just a joint
uh cloud 64 is just a joint yeah
[Laughter]
third round all right round three we got
25 from hoborg who says cluck cluck it's
in the bag 20 from just a box who says
can we get a sonic slash garfield combo
skin
wow
um
[Music]
ten dollars from will you're all lovely
people sending special uk vibes to tam
and lucy from leeds these leads i miss
ladies
where i went to uni
uh and then be devi with twenty dollars
thank you so much everyone tinyurl.com
playful2021 if you want to
donate hi sephiroth
holy [ __ ]
humbly wobbly now
um
let me
just
move these
nothing for sakura
yeah really last night
disgraceful
oh my god
are you joking
hold on
is this gonna work
surely not oh no
did that work
you're just an invisible man to me
i didn't work hold on let me try again
is someone just swimming
yes it worked i'm the gaping dragon from
dark souls oh my god
i wish i could see you
it's horrifying
it's um
yeah it's it's because you're like
weirdly small
yeah
we're five on one here i think i think
red team's gonna win this one i think
the other person is hiding because not
to
give away their location
but there's somewhere submerged in a
tank
huh
they also look like they're panicking
so it looks like they're stuck
oh there's a noise
here he is
oh wait we've got it we've got a homer
simpson garfield combo
oh
i've got a big homer simpson wearing a
garfield hat
out
here oh no we've got kirby with legs oh
no he's got he's got the hot women legs
[Music]
much skinnier than i
remember where's your cloak
i'm wearing it it's a scarf oh gosh
all right there you go oh boy oh no
there's a bubsy out here oh that's a
sora
oh that's me
yeah this this oh no what is what is the
noid doing to the homer
thing oh
no we can't show that's happening we
can't show that oh
whoa whoa
why how is there in a mode for that
we'll just take a quick peek though okay
oh they stopped they stopped
but snake is unfortunately
oh no
i think bubsy is old enough to see that
oh this kirby model is uh everything i
wanted oh no waluigi
[Laughter]
no
no no no no
[Music]
snake this is a stealth mission
oh boy sitting on this minion's face
jeff is there a vr
uh mode planned for this
i i don't know uh it seems like the sort
of thing that would eventually
that could eventually happen but uh boy
that'd be a real
i think that would that would add a
level to this disaster
yeah
but if you want that like vr chat has a
lot of models like this as well like the
ability to import models
and it's vr chat so it's kind of more
built for
for that um it does have some games and
stuff but i don't know i feel like this
is just a bit more fun but then i
haven't i haven't really tried vr chat
probably about six or nine months now i
have a parappa's here
finally rapid is dabbing
oh you can tell this is like ps2 rapid
two parappa yeah also i remember parappa
smoking in the video game but yeah
that's
well
it's a new feature in here
yeah well oh what's rough convict
emote
it's just a great dance
oh oh stop whoever's
oh no why is there oh gosh
oh no the b movie guy
jerry seinfeld
i'm disappointed that there is no john
cena
yeah i looked for john cena a little bit
earlier
and uh yeah
maybe maybe
um
jerry
seinfeld
uh
oh wait i can't believe you haven't had
this one yet
what is that
post malone
yep nasty way out of you oh did you find
anything
no
no post malone no post malone this is a
pre malone video game
um
so uh shall we hit the casino you want
ryan yeah yeah
gambling all right let's
get out of here and
i'm todd howard now if that helps
but the casino's right next door
okay i'm just going to grab whoever's on
my screen so oh i got sean impact from
paranoia
it's slightly different it's slightly
different are you still in the
oh wait i'm i will i'm just outside if
you leave laser tag
oh
wait i don't even know why i'm cursed
yeah
oh you are an upsetting shrek
that's like shrek the musical shrek yeah
oh hi tim oh why did i the green ranger
casino time oh
there's a nightclub
whoa yeah there's a nightclub you can
you can watch youtube videos together
and stuff like that or i think
soundcloud videos
guys i can be doggy cruiser one of the
best six rangers ever in the power
rangers
i love it like anywhere on earth it's
just this it's just the wheel of fortune
slot machine the most popular slime
machine in the history of bedding
wow we've made it to eleven thousand
dollars already
we're at 11 and a half 11 and a half
love to see it thank you to everyone
that is donating we are of course
raising money for ablegamers
which is combating social isolation and
uh improving the lives of disabled
gamers by making gaming more accessible
to them please donate generously if you
can
um and we haven't said it yet but we've
got a special surprise
announcement towards the end of this
stream
around what time is it in the
about 11 15
and then 45-ish yeah
um
oh my god ultimate hulk let's go
please be very big
uh he's not that big
oh that's a little disappointing yeah
also if uh you're not in a position to
donate simply just uh you know sharing
the stream yeah yeah
oh yeah does wonders
let's see who's uh playing the wheel of
uh fortune slots we've got chicken
the re4 vendor it's bear
jeff you're here
yeah yeah i'm trying to make up uh some
extra money for the starfield
development budget
someone someone
someone in the chat asked that
for a creamer
uh
there is no crime
but i am a painting i am a painting of
creamer currently
all right that's something
i feel like the most likely inclusions
are going to be models that are ripped
out of other games which is why i'm
surprised there's no jeff keely and
there's no conan o'brien
i literally just looked for jeff keely
and yeah he's not there
like since then it came out i've been i
feel like i
have been
wondering when we'll see those models
doing to me cream owl things and it
hasn't happened yet and
can of vienna sausages and i've never
felt more seen in my life oh my god
come on
i'm going to search for whatever food
there is i just have been food with
three o's in it so that's wrong
oh my god this is the one
go jeff go lucy i'm already in the i'm
already neo though
oh is that baked beans
i'm actually baked beans with arms and
legs
oh my god
i will dab
lucy maybe you should just have your
one-on-one in tower unite yeah
i'm gonna need you to download this and
uh
it's the new zoom don't worry it's uh
it's the new version of zoom just
install this and
like i'm into it
you have to sell this to me
yeah i'm gonna do the wave oh
oh the big king
this is just like vegas people falling
asleep on the floor yep yeah yeah
i feel like it was truly las vegas this
would be the airport and you would see
people sitting in the corner crying
yeah that's like a 40 to like it's
somewhere around a 50 chance that when
you go to the airport
you're gonna find someone in tears and
not and be like oh boy
i need to stop coming to this
l
hellhole
damn is just the windows
yep it's me windows
oh that's a cute link skin
and they're smoking a cigarette
okay
what is the king doing over there
is praying
worshiping
he's worshipping
oh hold on
a grudge match
i believe i'm playing slots next to
richard nixon
oh my god this mr beam
oh yeah no
what's this hand
no
no
it looks like the the thing from uh
adam's family get back here
he's playing texas hold him
where we're at
oh yeah
let's get in on a game
oh that's not it if you if you follow
diva from overwatch
um
and
there's the hand
oh
oh
i don't like this
yeah um oh mcdonald's surprise though
oh wait a minute
oh no that's why i've been loaded in for
me
like all the all of all the poker stuff
is not loaded it's so weird jfk
yeah someone's definitely jfk
those all came out of call of duty right
yeah
yeah is this putin
yeah it's wide
yeah that's like real flattened food
yeah
oh look at this
is this a cheese oh look at this burger
sandwich thing oh no so gross
it's like oh man look at the sesame
seeds on top of it
that doesn't look good
it looks so bad
what game
oh damn it's expensive to join hold them
huh yeah i don't have enough money high
stakes high stakes
200 at least for the lower uh
oh wait yeah there's one up there that's
cost forty thousand oh someone's just on
a warthog now
sure why not just the warthog
it says it costs 200 but you need 8 000
to play
oh probably uh because the minimum bet
will be yeah
oh wow someone is the um the uncharted 3
subway advert
oh yeah
this kim jong-un model is very good
i'm sad to report there's no uh bouncer
from the video game representative
no see on bar sorry
i love that subway sandwich
standing
on the poker table
oh i can be uh soma from food wars
though
this game is a nightmare
yeah it really is yeah
it's like yeah
nightmares while you're awake that's
what this game is
i'm very into it though
jeff did you order a glass of wine
no but i'll take one if you got it is
that yours
i searched for sandwich and it gave me
barry burton from resident evil
okay yeah it checks out
that search is working as intended yeah
yeah
oh it's just three goombas on top of
each other
oh i just realized
i'm homestar but i can't dab because
homestar doesn't have arms
oh look it's the this guy
the
oh my god if he turns around wait come
to the look at the door look at the door
is the guy on the door
and then
turn around
you want to
i feel like i'm bad at poker because i
like to play games and not fold
and that's not how you play this
i'm here to play video i'm here to play
games not watch other people play games
uh
wow this is a high stakes table going on
right now yeah real high sticks
[Music]
why is that musical cue yeah whenever
anyone unlocks an achievement it plays
it or like levels up because there's xp
and all sorts of other weird stuff in
there too
or was that mark zuckerberg
yeah he's he's in this
currently
oh man it's a snapchat hot dog
love that guy oh there's cursed shrek
augustus gloop is in this from charlie
and chocolate factory what
someone's really gone to their man
everyone is just partying in this casino
they're
they're gonna be upset that we're not
gambling
yeah there's someone just like
i'm dabbing in the card room
you can do this outside sir
someone has put in their baby
which is uh
a lot
oh no
heck yeah get that achievement person
yeah that was me getting one i think
the other problem with fake cards for
fake money is that people don't fold
when they're supposed to fold and so
everyone just stays in and
oh jackson eights it's illegal to be
this close to the dealer
yeah it can't this is yeah
no regulation here
i've got a few more donations one from b
devi for twenty dollars uh mambo a go-go
fifteen dollars went to buy tower unite
and already had it here's my purchase
price for a good cause instead thank you
all right on uh evan tran gave twenty
dollars and said thanks all chills this
said it's awesome seeing so many people
supporting such a great cause it was
also nice playing laser tag with you all
anonymous 20
anonymous 15
saying i want a biker grove podcast
with tomorrow lucy and jeff bakala biker
grove podcast that sounds like
because i mentioned that the ending of
biker grove being
okay the weirdest thing known to man
this person's wearing a kick me sign uh
lexan 10 anonymous 20. uh
carringer is four dollars and 20 cents
blaze it good job friends next time uh
victory will surely be ours don't kick
so hard okay
do not kick so hard
our king of red lions is in this let's
go
are you still playing that
hand that game
the big hand
the big hand oh god
oh i can be wrong
oh
this is
i am
so confused by this there's you can be a
box of for the uh for the henry the
hoover
maybe you're henry the hoover
someone's just dripping macaroni what's
that about
i don't want to know
oh no oh nice moe's here nice
almost like maybe
say someone's dissing your flag
oh this sonic
in a cart
wow oh there's there's ernie
yeah like a bad a real shitty ernie oh
he's vomited on me oh no
oh someone's just eating popcorn
yeah there's a whole shop so there's
there's also player housing in this you
can go decorate your own condo and and
buy stuff for it and yeah
yeah
that's my ace in three you did not hang
here i'd have to get off this table
[Music]
um oh it's a grandpa from rugrats
what oh my god look at that
roblox turkey leg
oh my god oh
hannah montana
i already i already searched i already
searched
she's not there
oh here we go here we go
jen try searching for keenan and orkel
oh my god
orange soda no
oh no charles esports cheese is here
all the cops
so good did you see he has a
he has an album now
um
you might have had one before but there
is a there's a new chucky cheese album
and is that joel from the last of us
oh no it's
arthur morgan over here um
yeah chuck e cheese has an album and he
has a song about how cool it is to do
crochet
it is cool to do that
i mean it is cool but i just never
thought that he would be the one
to kill the world
yeah there's so many the rest of the
casino is so empty and then you get to
the left
and it's just
bumping
yeah
um
i'm sad to report there's no jollibee
oh
i'm very upset okay
well uh should we play nightclub and see
what's up in there i don't know what it
means all right so it's uh there's a
door from the from the casino directly
into the nightclub if you walk out of
the poker room and turn left got it
okay what the [ __ ] is this wait i biffed
i biffed the graphic that we tweeted out
i said 10 p.m instead of 10 a.m
so i'm gonna quickly make a new one and
tweet it out
and then we're going to pretend like i
never did that
oh wow is it an epilepsy morning uh
wow
where did everyone go uh
i see how the president from metal gear
rising does in the nightclub
oh
are they playing baby got back
yeah yeah oh yeah you i think you can
submit like a soundcloud link
right yeah you can you can kind of
submit your own links to it and
that is dangerous
let's watch a giant bomb quick look huh
i'm not doing i'm not doing so hot on
billiards
wow
but um
nightclub has crashed my game
always regretted going to the nightclub
this is insanity i don't think you uh
well lucy because you're dobby maybe
dobby's too short for the pool table you
can't reach the oh no i'm being watched
by chuck e cheese
you walk up to the the dj station and
hold down q you can vote to skip a song
if you want
did someone put on uh the weezer song
from that boat game
i just got dm from the iron chic
on twitter so that's going to be
interesting
i'll deal with that later out ready i'll
deal with that
he's been doing me a lot
he is not
here my laptop
is
kicking off
a lot of really scary models dancing in
this club oh the brain age
yeah dr kawashima doctor
is here
yeah but just his gigantic polygonal
head
oh gross a yamcha is here
oh
nice
get back in your hole yamcha i mean they
won't get in
has anyone tried to see if yajirobe is
there
hopefully he's the right height
nope
oh man
no bananas
it's not crashing for you
yeah
i'm back now i'm gonna switch to lee so
i get there faster
oh i can just be sonic's shoes
just like corona to dance on the speaker
for too long and throw up all over the
club
uh i'm now exodia's right hand
it's crap
oh hell yeah
oh nice i'm a battle droid
where the [ __ ] is the nightclub again oh
okay yeah
finally we're going to learn something
in here today
making friendly conversations like this
is a big part of greeting
i love when the song comes up in the
club
yeah it really gets me gets me going
once they've paid for the meal no one
pays much
at old country buffet we work hard
as a what
oh just give it like a thumbs down
there's like
i don't know you know you're not going
to learn how to serve at the old country
buffet
uh the conversation you hold with guests
should be excuse me like the fitnessgram
pacer
how are tests once you've greeted the
guest start a brief conversation okay
try asking a question the guest can
answer innocent or two
you might ask something like this
is it still hot out there
where's the
oh there that's up here okay
so start conversations with children
all right
oh wait sorry how do i skip
uh give your thumbs down
[Music]
it's time to move on to this
nail's close
oh
put on
wait who put it's gamescom
yeah
obviously
my dreams have come true i'm a coffee
cart
and i keep throwing up in the club
this is beautiful this is the kind of
club i would want to be at yeah yeah
this is this is the type of social this
is the metaverse we deserve like a
lawless nightmare
where the comedy central logo when a
cowboy hat and glasses can stand back
and
smoke while
a coffee cart dances on the floor
any uh anytime anyone has ever
talked about a rave at an anime
convention this is what i've imagined
yeah this is what you imagine yes i'm
yeah
oh lonnie phantom whoa
[Music]
how did you find this game
um
some friends who are here in the server
with us
i started playing it uh
ramona over here who's dancing on stage
i think played it on stream uh and i was
like you know what
this is exactly the type of nightmare i
need to get into yeah
everyone's dancing real well
who is that very tall lady
oh yeah what
she's dripping macaroni too
she's one of the kick me sign
yeah
that's kind of kind of like what's your
name from bones
yeah
oh yeah
oh oh my god no no no i know who she is
that's um marishka hoggity's character
olivia benson from lawn order special
victims unit oh my god
where
the very tall lady
oh yeah it is huh but with like
big head i don't
let me find her
wait that that means there must be a
lawn order game
that checks yeah
there's loads of them uh yeah
yeah it's it's um
yeah we do need to get def jam models oh
we do
i feel like a distinct
wrestlers in this also
for as many wrestler models as there are
she is massive though
i'm playing as lady damage rescue and
i'm like a fraction of her size
nice nicely done
what in the world was that did you hear
that sledgehammer was that was that me
nice
it's the inca theme from oh yeah more
hits
something that my man johnny silverhand
can get into here
we have multiples oh no no
oh man i really want my song to come up
it's gonna be a while
no if we downvote all of them
how do you vote how do you speak in chat
uh hit y
okay
oops
for him to jump up on top of the
turntables and
and do this russian squat dance
exactly what he would do
blaze
oh my god
no
hello
lord
oh no is somebody that baby from village
is that you are
oh no
oh no
it's just very dark
oh
does the baby dab
oh this bart simpson thing looking thing
next to me is making me feel very sick i
hate it baby does not dab
[Music]
get this out of here
we need nine more
nine more
nine more down votes
tell him
i voted skip
um
oh that bart simpson is [ __ ] up yeah
it's like terrifying right what is it oh
wait where is the homer
yeah
i got sonic in rouge's alpha
[Music]
which is amazing sonic and rouge's
outfit is uh
everything you've wanted
quiet look
oh you know what how come
i wonder let me let me come and find jen
so the stream can see sonic and rouge's
outfit there we go someone's back here
playing as a helicopter
yeah
there is no lola bunny
but there is buff winnie the pooh oh my
god look at my ass
look at you tam
yeah
hold on hold on hold on let me do it
let me do a
oh yeah uh what
drop it drop it drop it drop it what a
party we got going on here
everyone just sort of
decided to accept the song and really
just
lincoln sausage sausages yeah that's
pretty good
[Music]
oh god
a sonic next to me in a car
jeffy i fixed the um i fix the graphic
if you wouldn't mind retweeting the
right one thanks
oh no who's this
is this person actually dead like they
don't have a username above them oh
no have we been if we've been privy to a
crime
and we all we're gonna solve this crime
and another one of this club is a
murderer
they vanished
oh wait holy [ __ ]
we got some more donations
uh we got emerito since 20 is literally
my favorite internet people creating a
beautiful nightmares together can't
thank you enough um
i keep doing what you do the world
deserves this madness
asylum runner 69
and then the comment was tim allen grunt
so oh
that was really good
thank you very much yes
very good put some work uh
yeah i've been practicing that a lot tim
um skyscraper gave twenty dollars
anonymous gave five dollars
shane tynan gave twenty dollars
anonymous twenty dollars and then
uninvincible gave five hundred dollars
wow
yeah i think you can i think it just
like
like an inner tube around you or
something
like the hats and so yeah you can
customize the models on top of that
oh brand oh there's the
best skin
i've i found bowsette
[Music]
i found merrell from metal gear
oh yeah
[Music]
what is this what is
this sounds of art is being excited for
for four minutes
i voted to skip
this video
skip skip
we need to get down to it's gamescom
we gotta hear the gamescom song
because this feels like a gamescom
is it because everyone's throwing up on
the floor yeah everyone's going up
there's like a weird club
and like nothing makes sense
oh look at this chubby pikachu
oh it's just throwing up off the dj
booth
accurate
oh my god one more skip one more skip
come on skip hi welcome to subway
okay sweet we're in
oh it's this this one's short as well so
we'll get the gamescom song next
let's go
what that's the question
how is it doing that
all right we've got a few more donations
like shane tynan tinan 20
anonymous 20 spring fart 10
this is the best nightclub i've ever
been to
thank you everyone tinyurl.com slash
play for 2021
i really don't like the way wario
waluigi is looming over the dance floor
over there
his eyes are just he's doing the robot
i'm gonna get a drink oh hi ben
[Music]
okay i'm gonna be i don't think this
will be in the game
but i'm just gonna try and search it
all right
oh the crusty crab is here
and then we can move on it's just a
piece of pizza it's no john leguizamo
yeah well
all right it's time
here we go
i'm getting ready to dance
lose your mind
gamescom
kyle bosman classic
kyle bosman
and his
german was it his german
yeah was it nemesis uh
oh you can have a job if i stand here i
am earning points
he's on he's on the wall over here
it's gamescom oh no
gamescom
gamescom alan wonder world is in here oh
yeah
uh oh i've been that guy for quite a
while now okay i just switched to the oh
god i can't i feel like i'm taking
psychic damage by
using this model
this definitely feels like gamescom
i'm impressed by the person who
committed to the comedy central logo
yeah someone's really committed to the
bit
wait this
karaoke what
yeah i saw karaoke rooms i don't know
what i don't know what is actually what
happened you have to you have to get in
a room um
come come over here
there has to be a couple of people go in
the room i'm gonna pick room one
um
if you're facing the stage go to the
left yeah yeah and then
posted by can't get in
oh wait do i have to talk to this person
karaoke over here yeah you might think
yeah you gotta register you gotta
register okay okay make a booking all of
a sudden everyone line up everyone line
up a single file
just came in to do karaoke
[Applause]
who has seven and a half grand who can
get us 15 minutes of karaoke
i've had to ask you for permission
this is uh quite the hot ticket
who do we got in line
uh vape charming won the chainsaw
deathmatch so good luck good on them
oh my song is playing
back downstairs
everyone back and dance
it's just a burger and
jesse from toy story here
oh that's great
what's this dream
this is like american cinema right here
not yeah
it's
john leguizamo just
in his prime
looks like the karaoke rooms are just
private youtube viewers oh private
which you can have you can put tvs in
your in your player housing like in your
condo or whatever to watch youtube
videos there too
oh my god it's the lamp
the ice age annoying uh
character what's his name said the sloth
stead yeah but he's got toast in his
mouth
oh so he's out of there
yeah we got twenty dollars from helmut
krueger who says please try to be chief
o'brien from star trek and keep up the
good work
twenty dollars from liam h
who said ballon wonder wonder world more
like badland wonder hull
ow and then 100 i mean
and then 100 from anonymous why did you
do this to us jan
uh
this game or this song
everything i imagine ever yeah this is
all this is the catch-all
i typed in
no one came out
yeah uh
even picard
well i talked to star trek and it gave
me kenshiro from fifth southern north
star so close enough i mean that's
pretty much
yeah
oh that was great that was great thanks
guys for letting me play that song
yeah um i'm gonna go i'm gonna run off
and try to find the matchmaking hub uh
and yeah let's do that
[Music]
back by the shops
what the [ __ ] is this
okay so uh
how do you get out of it
so if you run out of the nightclub i'm
over here by a
map
uh there's like a like a mall style
placard over here
and go there we want to go to the mini
games arena no wait sorry that's hang on
we want to go to
if you hit m you can um
oh yeah oh there we go oh okay yeah fast
travel oh yeah you fought you confessed
yeah yeah
uh where are we going
right now no yeah
oh uh no hmm
oh we can go to the beach
is the matchmaking area not on here
oh yeah i'm at mini games arena maybe
i'm at the wrong place
yeah i'm gonna go there too and see
me too
someone said stay here with me slinky
dog we don't need them to have fun
that's nice
so many games happen on a timer yeah
this this isn't uh so like every 15
minutes a minigame will will kind of
happen here automatically
um match making a server the game port
is what you want okay yeah that's the
game okay
games
ports it's very top
top one got it
hello
okay now we've got it's like the laser
tag type thing it's uh
alex
from persona
uh yeah i'll accept
i'm going then
oh and then we pick one of these games
here yeah yeah
um
it looks good i have not played most of
these so i don't know accelerate looks
like a mario kart style thing
oh ball race
fall race um
[Music]
someone works on a plane
i'm here to ball race
[Music]
about race
oh there's a master i don't want to hear
any of it
uh
random
here we go
all right
let's race these balls
all right oh
[Music]
one hit random too
uh
i mean polar race
loading glitzy
ready up
i think we are in two separate ball
races
uh-oh
i think
this looks impossible
what
oh my god oh god oh god
oh
there's no collision with anyone else
though
oh you have to keep moving oh i did the
finish what the hell there we go
[Music]
okay
did it
won i don't know
our legend
i think looks like i may have finished
second over on server that i'm on
but
oh yeah back laura i think we're in the
same one you got there yeah
oh brand just oh no just bit it big time
oh
oh we oh there we go there's some money
oh oh oh
look i'm falling to his death
as you hoped oh we all just died we all
just ate it for no reason
oh no
oh [ __ ] all right i'm on this one wait
what are we supposed to do here i think
to the end
oh yeah right
this is impossible
[Music]
well you know something bootleg monkey
ballers
oh oh
he's gonna do it oh
[Music]
getting money though
yeah so like you know
the casino this is kind of how you can
earn some money
no no no no all right
[Music]
okay
what
oh my god this crazy golf is uh are you
kidding me with this [ __ ] got him
oh what
that's right hogan good job take a dive
again
i don't realize those like laser things
can suck you up
oh no
just got a hole in one guys
nice
ball race
super monkey ball race
oh
what
okay all right
oh no oh no that's no good
how are people doing this one
yeah what the [ __ ] are you supposed to
do here
oh okay okay
you just like hover on top
oh wow
you are on much harder levels than i am
enough yeah we are going on over there
that's a possible world
okay
fortune and glory
no oh
nuts
[Music]
i'm fully stuck on this level this is
this is where to make the money right
here
okay okay
oh my god
what's what happens if you get like a
watermelon what's that do for you i
don't know maybe it just points reduce
your time or you know maybe some kind of
little bonus
no chance no chance
okay here we go here we go
i wish this was more like trackmania and
i could keep making attempts as long as
there was time because i'm finishing
once and then like man if i had another
shot at this i bet i could do a lot
better but
wow this chicken is taking this race
very seriously i can't believe that
[Music]
oh
who chose the skill with my bonus [ __ ]
wait what
how did we get
[Music]
i died you got you got pop dude i don't
even understand how to get over there
oh no
oh
no
wow i did it
you did it
no no not really
okay
oh i can't go that way what the hell
this is the most frustrating [ __ ]
oh my god this specific ball race
this ball this is the worst ball race
there ever was
i don't know where i'm supposed to go
no
okay speed run
no one fit we were on a level that no
one finished i think oh we've had a
bunch of those
oh oh so close
[Music]
oh no way is anyone finished dude
somewhere i think you might be muted
somehow
i don't know i can't believe that
sorry if i felt like we were ignoring
you that was not the case i was mostly
just screaming about uh this ball race
that i was doing
it's a nice impossible [ __ ]
oh the quiet town
i'm pretty excited for
that monkey ball remaster
they announced i wasn't
uh
just got me off balls for good
whoa
nothing's gonna get me off balls
oh
dude no
i can't believe this person keeps
finishing
this is their jam backlar what kind of
like ball race
oh come on
monster are you
i tried to
jump to the bottom but it wouldn't let
me dude
this is not a game anyone can
play this is just absurd
what are we doing very into this
it's it's fairly track mania-like in
some ways
having everyone in here at the same time
like this and
oh how long does this go on for though
like uh 14 levels we're on level 10
right now so we're 13.
uh yeah i'm on over 10.
okay
i don't know what to do oh okay
the music on the level i'm on is very
like antagonizing
i love how this red button does nothing
i'm stuck on an island
and we cannot go anywhere i'm with you
on an island and nobody knows what to do
oh there's the finish
wait
where is this oh i see it hogan oh [ __ ]
no
oh i believe it's called hogan knows
best
oh get in there i got it ah man
oh god
oh my lord
oh my lord
oh look at this half pipe okay we're out
of there now
what how did
one character's got like a cube instead
of a
sphere yeah i think you can buy just
cosmetic
upgrades for each game
uh as you play more of it they're
really unnerving
okay that's i'm stuck now
forever this is this is how i die this
is how it ends for me
i'm like i'm caught in the [ __ ] here
oh i did it i think i did it almost
there how'd you how did you get up that
ramp backwards
you got to like flippy dip you around
oh flippy dippy got it
oh
oh man
i think i'm having fun
yeah this is good
yeah i'm not mad i was man i'm not mad
anymore
we passed the uh
12k mark we're approaching 12 000.
[Music]
but also i fell to my death
oh god
um yeah we got a donation from mr
shakedown for ten dollars
all right
i said i convinced some people to donate
nice uh conor milan 14.33
a happy friday and then anonymous 25
thank you
amazing
oh no the ball game has crashed again
i don't know how to get there oh i'm
spectating you and you're not moving
yeah it's crashing
no no land
oh
there it is
oh how do i get there where am i five
seconds jen
go
there it is there it is
finished somehow
we all finish
how do i leave mini golf
you're still amazing oh no no no i'm
having a nice time it's just really
difficult
oh that sounds like mini
and like most of the people i was
playing with have left as well
oh get out of here with these magnetic
pole thing these things
they're the worst oh
i might have won that one
oh god crash i got rebooted
what is up with your
it's too much the cost of innovation
it's the cost of innovation
[Music]
tower unites not gonna build itself
actually i think it does i mean yeah
it's early access
it seems
it seems self-aware
grew out of a gary's mod mode
um
that they then
crowdfunded to do kind of a standalone
thing
oh that was the easiest one yet oh
no
no
[ __ ]
okay
this is it's so weird everything's so
weird just embrace it back boy
let's go with it man
no i i am i just feel like whoa you know
when you're like oh my nightmares are
the scariest things i see
i'm awake and i'm seeing this and that's
bad oh my god
you are freaking out man
that was great your head between your
knees and some orange wedges
yeah i just need a couple uh
oh i need to leave bags to breathe into
i guess so i just saw a character
running away from the casino it's like
really funny yeah this is like get me
out of here like oh my lord get me out
of there
oh god oh there's no one so i asked
oh man i asked steve to pop on it like
uh in about five minutes
okay
um
because we'll have a little a special
guest for the end of the stream
help me i can't escape the mini off
there's a there's an evil cat outside
the mini golf area it just says mini
golf upgrades here which is
very concerning
that's why uh holland character
oh god i'm just
weeping
yeah mini golf upgrades i don't trust
that cat
no
should we jump into another mini game or
head back
somewhere we head back because if we got
about five minutes um
yeah special guest maybe we should uh
i'm hanging out seriously though how do
i leave this mini game
that's a great question i was gonna say
you might be able to just hit escape and
go to plazas and then
rejoin the lobby from there which one
are we in again
east two two two yeah cool
yeah let me try that
i was stuck
well get that cool square for the
monkey ball
game
and get a dodecahedron
just a random shape
oh some of these shapes you can't even
buy until you have leveled up in ball
race enough to earn it so you got a
whole progression
kind of cool
ah i'm sad to report there's no doug
from the show
funny
oh
no there's the green eminem though what
about roger i'd play as roger
uh we have shaggy rogers
and big o
oh god
it's just like a gun behind me
um
question is just any big
what happens if i just type in a gun
can i be one of the cowboys from gun or
perhaps oh yeah here we go just a big
floating gun
with a jet pack
and the gun dab
oh where's sonic hell yeah look at this
werehog
oh no
oh hey it's what's his face from doug
oh yeah is that who's that
um the neighbor
oh weird
oh gross
lord another lady has uh got a
uh hot dog in her hand
he's using it like a gun
i'll crack a touchdown here
[Music]
the warehouse is a lot
uh
[Applause]
wait where was sora
god
no god hand whoever asked that on the
giant bomb chat
um
i'm gonna be getting
caught oh
oh hell yeah
someone in the game switch out is this
skylanders what the [ __ ] is this
i'm drobop
um a forklift operator
i'm wargreymon
i want to be a gengar
um
well i found gengar by typing in goofy
so
oh i just typed in gengar and i got
genga
i'll meet wads here
samus oh yeah bring it in guys
can gengar dab
oh my god no no no no
hell yeah
he can dab
but he looks mad
oh look at me
where's gengar where's gengar there we
go
his his like
eyes and his nose go into his mouth when
he dabs
yeah yeah yeah
here we go
we couldn't find jeff keely or
and but we did have todd howard and now
we have sam lake
as oh hell yeah
yeah there he is hell yeah
oh this is a very upsetting version of
of ren
where are you oh god i see you from far
away that's pretty horrific
oh no it's not good
not good
[Laughter]
look how low his eyeballs are popping
out of his skull
this is terrible oh my god
oh the giant tom nook
[Laughter]
oh my god
oh there's a lot of tony hawks that's
pretty good giant
whoa
oh what is that
somehow more nightmarish than it was
when we started
mr escape from exit is in this
for anyone that remembers that game
yeah i do remember that game
mr escape
was that like a psp game right
yeah
steve says he's on uh
okay yes
all right
i can fade to that and three
oh
lucy you're good to make the
announcement
i guess so
all right folks we haven't even told you
guys what the announcement is but it's
very exciting
no idea what's happening from uh
y'all are seeing
you can change the scene in three two
hey steve
hi steve hey hey hey
hey
how's it going friends how are you
good you're going well thank you
yeah we played a game which is just
seems to be like just hell on earth
incarnated
a lot of dabbing which i didn't yeah
i did it we did it um but yeah we got
you on here because one uh to thank you
for helping us out
um over the last uh week or so in um
getting all this uh charity stuff uh off
the ground
but also because you know uh we
we wanted to make an announcement that
comes by way of our uh our company our
parent company and i'll let lucy give
the uh do the actual announcement but um
before we make it we just want to
kind of impress upon everyone that this
is a charity that we as a team
both giant bomb and gamespot and
everyone that works alongside us truly
truly believe in and believe that it's
such a force for good and obviously
steve being one of the masterminds
behind it we wanted to have you here for
the
um for the announcement that we make um
so yeah lucy
yeah so
uh our parent company at red ventures is
uh is gonna be making a donation to the
tune of a hundred thousand dollars to
ablegamers
[Music]
so that on top of the 12 and a half
grand that we raised this week
um yeah yep that is coming your way
awesome
fantastic thank you so much
yeah and i remember we when we uh we
kind of like were meeting with steve and
hanging out for the initial uh
discussions you were talking about the
spawn together
campaign so and you were you're wanting
to get it to a million um
by
your birthday so can you tell uh tell us
a bit about that just so other people
who might be inclined to either donate
or uh you know kind of put together
their own charity campaign um can do so
absolutely so
the spawn together initiative was sort
of
just born out of the need to
help ablegamers get funding i myself am
somebody who has terminal illnesses and
you know without you never know how long
you're going to be around for so i
thought to myself well what if i'm not
around one day to harass tam and lucy
and get them to talk good things about
us right so what happens after those
days are gone and uh you know one of the
things i came up to was in the middle of
a panini what are you supposed to do for
your 40th birthday and that's what i
came up with you know i've already met
cool people on the internet i have a
good friends
what if we raise a lot of money for a
really good cause and help some people
with disabilities be able to play games
and so the goal was to raise a million
dollars in a year through
community-based efforts so no reaching
out to get you know a top-tier streamer
for like mr beast or someone who just
has that in pocket change lying around
oh here's a millionaire or whatever here
you go so it was like this was
grassroots people raising a hundred
dollars at a time and i'd love to have
you all out there come and help us out
my thanks certainly to all of our
friends that yeah this is the lovely
play for all you know from redventures
and gamespot and giant bomb and all of
you thank you so much uh for helping us
out with this if you want to go and
check out the tiltifier look up spawn
together spawn you can see it all over
the current uh social media on all of
these wonderful human being sites you
can go join up right now and we're doing
it a hundred dollars at a time raising
that money it costs 350 to change
somebody's life
for the for the better for the
permanently uh and that's that's what
you can do right here right now one
dollar at a time we can make a
difference for all the future gamers who
just want to play games like everyone
else
absolutely and yeah you can you can we
want to try and get to a lot we want to
try and get steve uh his his goal of 1
million by the end of the campaign um so
please do if you can um and you know
every little helps you might think that
you you don't have enough power to or
like enough of exposure to to make a
difference but you genuinely do so if
you can um please do try and you know
put some uh kind of a backing behind it
um yeah so
that's been a week of streaming for us
and
i think
it's been incredibly exciting it's been
a lot of fun we had a lot of cool people
on and we ended it um
the best way possible getting our
good friends and colleagues at giant
bomb
together and dropping into a game where
we could be ridiculous characters and
play
hang out at a nightclub where jan puts
on some sort of song where a man was
flicking boogers at one point
i was watching all from the stream and i
really liked sort of the meta of that
because your entire play for all
campaign was to help gamers with
disabilities be able to play in those
kind of virtual environments where you
can go and hang out with your friends
those are the kind of environments that
are great for people with disabilities
because a lot of people who are in
wheelchairs who can't go to clubs we go
there in games we go have fun and games
with our friends and staying together
playing for everybody all the same time
that is what this whole campaign is all
about being able to play together so
everyone can game
absolutely loves it agreed
well with that said i think it's time
for us to sign off um
thank you everyone for joining us lucy
any final words
i just want to say a huge thank you to
everyone who has donated watched along
at home shared the streams that we've
been doing and of course all of the
great people that we've had on
uh to come help us raise money like
we've had a week a week's worth of uh
folks that we love folks that we admire
and we've had some really fun times and
raise a lot of money obviously thank you
to our parent company for the really
generous donation and special thanks to
steve because we only really started
doing like we do
extra life every year but
in terms of like big charity campaigns
it's something that we want to certainly
do more of and steve you have been
so gracious with your time and help when
we have asked questions you're like yeah
this is a good idea or this isn't a good
idea and you've always been so
responsive and uh it's been so great
working with you on this and um yeah
big shout out to eric tay and jean-luc
psyche um who have not been on any
streams but have been in the background
helping out
um
like last minute requests the whole
thing and just making sure the tech goes
smoothly so they are the unsung heroes
of this whole thing
yeah total just jumped by nine hundred
dollars look at that yeah yeah
it's gone up to
13 000 and it's continuing to go um yeah
we've got a bunch of donations a few i'm
just going to call out thomas l um
neil's on who donated and said if the rv
can donate 100k then i can donate
another 10 bucks thank you so much uh
matt's a couple of anonymous in there
steve
um
luke will
uh otaku coder mr hazard and there's
there's so many coming through right now
um rolling fury gave a hundred dollars
and said i'm a disabled disabled gamer
here thank you for working for such a
worthy cause
uh yeah so thank you so much to everyone
that that donation link is going to stay
open for a little while longer so if you
want to add to the
to the money that we have already raised
please do um but otherwise yeah go to go
to ablegamers and learn about the
amazing work that you're doing
um and we'll see you later
thank you everyone
thank you
you